Transcriber: emine altıntaş
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Herkese merhaba. Benim adım Yağmur Cesur.
Ben TED’e Yazıkent Koleji Esenyurt
kampüsünden katılıyorum.
Bugün sizlere viviseksiyondan bahsedeceğim
Öncelikle viviseksiyon nedir ?
Viviseksiyon,bilimsel amaçlar için cerrahi
tekniklerle hayvanları parçalara ayırma
işlemine denir.
Peki bir viviseksiyon neden yapılır?
İlaç geliştirmede ve kozmetik ürünlerin
güvenilirliğini arttırma adı altında
gerçekleştirilir.
Birçok hayvana zarar verir ve
sağlıklarını temelden etkiler.
Ben size birazcık Hadmek’ten
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Hadmek,hayvan kullanım oranlarını belli bi
istatistik altında toplayan bir kurumdur.
Burada da Türkiye'nin hayvan kullanım
oranını görüyorsunuz.
Bir başka bahsetmek isteğim başlık ise
antiviviseksiyonizm.
Antiviviseksiyonizm ise viviseksiyona
tamamiyle karşı olan bir başlıktır.
ve iki başlık altında incelenir.
Birinci başlık bilimsel itiraz.
İkinci başlık ahlaki itiraz.
Öncelikle bilimsel itiraz hayvanları
yapılan deneylerin ve viviseksiyonun zaman
içerisinde insan fizyolojisine uymayacağı
için insan sağlığını olumsuz yönde
etkileyeceğine dayanır.
Ahlaki itiraz ise tamamıyla hayvanlara
yapılan deneylerin fiziksel ve psikolojik
bir şiddet olduğuna ve bunun yani amacı
ne olursa olsun hiçbir şekilde kabul
edilemez bir ahlaki yanlış
olduğuna inanır.
Peki bu viviseksiyon için geliştirilmiş
bazı alternatifler var mıdır?
Evet, vardır.
Bilim adamları bunun için bazı
çözümlere başvurmuşlardır.
Bunlardan bazıları bilgisayar silico’da
modelleme,insan hasta simülatörleri
in nitro testleri ve insan gönüllülerde
araştırma
Bunlar bilim adamlarının buldukları
bazı alternatifler.
Peki biz bir birey olarak gündelik
hayatımızda bunun önüne geçebilmek için
neler yapabiliriz?
Öncelikle bir yerden bir ürün satın
alacağımızdan, satın alacağımız ürünün
her hangi bir hayvana zarar verip
verilmediğini, yapım aşamasında bir
hayvana deney yapıp yapmadığına
emin olmamız gerekiyor.
Peki biz bundan nasıl emin olacağız?
Öncelikle ürünün üzerinde cruelty free ve
vegan olduğuna dair bir logo bulunacaktır.
O logoya dikkat etmeliyiz.
Ayriyeten gerekirse eğer markalarla
birebir iletişime de geçebiliriz.
Bunun yanı sıra bunun için geliştirilmiş
bazı telefon uygulamaları da vardır.
Uygulamanın uygulamanın kullanımı
çok basittir.
Uygulamaya girildiğinde ürünün barkodu
uygulamaya okutuluyor ve uygulama size
detaylı bir şekilde ürünün yapım
aşamasında herhangi bir hayvanın üzerine
deney yapıp yapılmadığını size
verileriyle sunuyor.
Bir başka çözüm ise kulağa zor gelecek
ama kendi kozmetik bakım ürünlerimizi
kendimiz evimizde üretebiliriz.
Bunun için doğal yağlar, esanslar,
doğal içerikler kullanabiliriz.
Böylece ürünümüzün nereden geldiğinin
neden yapıldığını , yapım aşamasında
herhangi bir hayvana zarar verip
verilmediğinden %100 bir şekilde emin
olup gönül rahatlığıyla kullanabiliriz.
Sürdürülebilirlik açısından hayvan
deneyleri kesinlikle bir son bulmalıdır.
Alternatiflerin yanı sıra üzerinde cruelty
free olmasına dikkat etmeliyiz.
Bu zulmün, ekosistemin çok büyük bir
parçası olan hayvanların neslinin tükenme
tehlikesini artık bir dur demeliyiz.
Ben de bir genç olarak üzerime düşeni
yapıyorum ve hayvanların neslinden bazı
tehlikeye girmesini istemiyorum.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.